دائمًا ما يكون الجلوس لتناول وجبة لذيذة
طريقة جيدة لإنهاء اليوم ، فقط تأكد من
أنها ليست أكبر وجبة تناولتها طوال
اليوم وفقًا لدراسة أولية أجرتها
النساء في جمعية القلب الأمريكية اللائي
استهلكن المزيد من السعرات الحرارية اليومية في
وقت لاحق.  في المساء أكثر
عرضة للإصابة بأمراض القلب والأوعية الدموية مقارنة
بالنساء اللائي لم يقمن بالدراسة ،
وتتبع المشاركون ما تناولوه لمدة أسبوع واحد
في بداية الدراسة ولمدة أسبوع واحد بعد
12 شهرًا وجد الباحثون
أنه في حين أن معظم المشاركين في الدراسة
تناولوا بعض الطعام بعد  6 م  أولئك
الذين استهلكوا نسبة أعلى
من السعرات الحرارية اليومية بعد ذلك الوقت يعانون من
ضعف في صحة القلب ومع كل 1٪
زيادة في السعرات الحرارية المستهلكة بعد
الساعة 6 مساءً.  زادت احتمالية ارتفاع
مؤشر كتلة الجسم لضغط الدم وضعف
التحكم على المدى الطويل في نسبة السكر في
الدم ، وبينما
اعتبرت هذه الدراسة عينة صغيرة فقط من 112
خبيرة تقول إنها خطوة مهمة
لفهم العلاقة بين
النظام الغذائي وعوامل الخطر القلبية الوعائية
لصحة اليوم  دقيقة أنا بريت كونواي